anyone out there at all tired of the
agenda driven politicians just blabbing
to us and going on and on same thing day
in and day out well who better to hear
from than the people who actually pay
the bills and see what's happening on a
daily basis last night in Nashville at
the Grand Old opery House Raymond and I
had the chance to talk to some of these
voters so what's their main concern Joe
Biden it's not just the number of the
age being 81 it's the mental acuity of
the person he is not mentally capable of
doing the job he wasn't in 2020 remember
and he still won you know he still won
because you know again there's a lot of
factors that come into play but he's not
going to run a campaign they've already
said they he's not going to campaign the
media will campaign for him that's
what's going to happen and Obama and
Michelle and and all the
rest I think one of the things that we
have to look at has Republican is what
are we going to do to be getting out the
vote the Democrat kills us every major
election because they are so successful
at registering
voters the Republicans are falling
behind in that effort and the polls the
numbers look great but every time we
start counting the votes I get
disappointed and concerned because we
don't have those votes well State party
state state parties are responsible for
getting out the vote so State Republican
parties um I have to you know I mean
it's not it's not again it's not rocket
science we have the data it's microt
targeting of Voters you know how people
voted over the last four election cycles
and most micr targeting it's actually
going to their house do you have your
ballot have you turn it in you know
let's let's go mail it let we'll get you
to the polls I mean it it it requires
frankly all Americans who have a little
bit of time to frankly get involved we
want to ask people
who they want to be the next president
of the United States of the people who
are possibilities okay who are out there
possibilities raise your hands if you're
for Donald
Trump very very good there's a few
people who aren't in the front you hold
outs you hold out you're not 100% um D
santis Ron
DeSantis oh there's a clap two two hands
and a clap
okay Joseph Biden oh come
on not even a not even a we how about
Nikki Haley yes a lot of people are
looking at Nikki Haley now how about
Nikki haey show of hands Nikki Haley
there's half hand yeah I like that look
they did this a kind of that's a kind of
weak half a hand maybe not I'm still
deciding that was the angle the angle
has the angle has offered our show as a
platform for Nikki Haley to debate Ronda
santis we want settle this once and for
all there has to be Trump versus someone
else so that's why I think a real
substantive debate maybe no moderator
just Nikki Haley versus DeSantis I think
that would be awesome because because
it's the populist kind of America First
populist versus a you know more
traditional Republican more globalist in
in some some views not everything but
it's more of a traditionalist versus a
populist conservative I think to me
that's a beautiful thing and Ronda santz
said he would do it did all of you enjoy
seeing um President Biden with uh King X
in San Francisco did you enjoy those
moments where where we we actually he he
really kind of spruces up really nicely
when he meets his boss don't you well
the town the town was sparkling yeah you
had to it all clean as you could eat off
the floor in the uh in the in the subway
no dropping on the street yeah the BART
was all clean clean all right here's
what Biden had to say about Governor
Gavin Nome watch this I want to talk
about Governor Nome want to thank him
he's been one hell of a governor
man not the fact he could be anything
you want he could have the job I'm
looking for well at this point he might
uh here's my question should Biden drop
out of the race at this
point Round of
Applause no you want to run against why
why should he drop out Biden quite
obviously is no way up to the job right
and so uh it's very clear and the most
powerful country in the world that's
going downhill in incredible ways
there's no way that guy should continue
to lead this country the the anxiety of
of working people middle class even a
little upper middle class is growing in
the United States how many of you have
changed your plans vacation plans travel
plans because of financial concerns over
the
past 18 months 2 years we're just not
going to take any vacations that are uh
utilize our money we're putting it away
and waiting for that rainy day because
I'm afraid it's going to happen we own a
business we're doing the same thing with
it um you know I think it's going to get
worse before it gets better and I just
know that you know four years ago before
this we were we've done better than we
ever have and now that four years is
gone I mean it's I'm back to where I was
four years ago you know when we had
Trump in office and uh so we're we're
just going to hold on and hopefully see
a new uh president come in I think it's
more than changing their vacation plans
I think it's even I we are blessed but
um I come from workingclass family and I
Chang the way I shop for my groceries
and where I shop for my groceries and
where I put gas in my car the better
question yeah and I I think that's the
part that hurts
everybody everybody feels it almost
almost regardless of what economic you
know uh status you're in you live in
just those day-to-day decisions and we
all feel it I mean I mean right gallon
of milk I mean everything insurance and
and I mean it's every part of your life
I think we were talking the other day
Raymond and I and I said if if I were
running for office the number one thing
I would say on a national base I would
say by the time I get through with my
presidency gas is going to be a lot
closer to $2.30 a gallon again that's I
mean I think just running on energy the
energy issue itself is just so powerful
well and crime and crime shut down the
Border get gas prices low get
independent more man American
manufacturing hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else